[Music]
there's a man who was left with chronic
back pain after trying to suck his own
penis that's what you get though
that's what you get he's been over like
this this whole time that's why everyone
says take yoga did he bend this way or
this way i don't understand why is he
bending to suck his own penis oh yours
yours reaches your chin like mine i see
you know you know what i'm talking about
no one else does no one else knows what
we're talking about right now
it's [ __ ] up actually my mind's like
this far away i could lick it but really
yeah damn yeah we only have one dick
sucking professional here so let's go
ahead and turn him good joe explain how
you would do this
like that
ah
like that
if you have chronic pain that means you
must be trying like hours a week
differently than everyone else
i don't know it's my i'm ex letting my
air out it's not the easiest way to be
on your back and then just like oh
oh
like you throw your legs over you
dominating though
no i don't want to be dominated almost
gets his own dick suck every time he
does that one trick
wow he lands on his head trying to suck
his little dick like that have you guys
ever dreamt that you did that [ __ ] your
own [ __ ]
you wake up you're like
i've dreamt that i did that
walk us through the shoes
you're sucking your own dick when you
woke up the fact you're not calling it a
nightmare is concerning
if you if success if you could the real
treat if you guys could in your horniest
time in junior high and high school dude
for sure would you have done it
in that time you would just do it to be
[ __ ] hilarious yeah i don't know
about funny
maybe we have different mindsets
i don't even need the perimeter of
junior high high school like if it
happened like if i could do it now
like i'd be like i gotta go to the
bathroom
and like
i i kind of agree if i could i would
would you jizz in your mouth you're not
oh that feels good because it it feels
good you know what's crazy
what's great is bart goes you know how
good that feels nah playa i don't like i
don't know shots of the mouth bro it
feels good
it doesn't feel like a waterpik
toothbrush
i wonder how if it would distract like
if it will take away from how good the
dick feels because it's in your mouth
while you're choking yourself the back
of your throat you're you're feeling
good and you're feeling gag at the same
time yeah yeah would you just in your
own mouth no i don't think so follow it
i don't believe i'm good
tickle yourself because you never want
to swallow but if you said
the gagging thing is a good point though
because like you know
not everyone gags because it you know
you don't need to but like would you gag
for your own your own stuff
yeah yeah yeah would i deep throat
myself yeah like would it go so far that
my balls are also in my mouth yeah would
you be like
i don't i don't mean this but this is
for you
wow
honestly when i brush my teeth and i
clean my tongue i'm gagging all the time
dude so i don't i think so you you brush
your tongue you brush your teeth always
how do you brush your tummy brush your
teeth
oh that's how you do that yes i just
wanted that shot yeah and you could edit
this edit that you can edit a dick in my
hand if you guys want
tonsils and everything i can't reach
that far i honestly i honestly believe
all guys if they could they would
i think so even secretly even secretly
even secretly i think i think so i think
you try it in their mouth no i don't
think that
but i do think that they would they
would go down on the side i'm gonna
follow the penis in my mouth though okay
it's mine but here's the question and it
also pertains to the article how old is
too old for you to try to suck your own
dick
why would there be an age i did the
flexibility thing i don't know dude
because i feel like kids like uh when
you're growing up like middle school
you're like oh yeah i wanna i wanna try
to suck my own dick but as you get older
it's like i seriously well yeah cause
you're not because you know you can't
though yeah imagine you try and then you
do and you're like honestly that was way
better than my hand how bad do you want
to
suck your own dick
that's what it comes down to i think
it's virgin movies yeah like when you
have never had your dick sucked before
you're so curious you might want to yeah
you won't know what it feels like but
then if you already can get your dick
sucked then why would you use your own
mouth for it
you know what no one knows your penis
i know i know that i can get a hand job
right but i know that when i give myself
a hand job i'm the best in the world
but i still prefer hanging let me see
show me how good it is talking all this
[ __ ] dude let me see i could last
forever when i'm with somebody else and
i'm the man i'm a king one of myself i
can't last more than five seconds
andy before you try to suck your own
dick do you tie your own hair up and
then go for the guys along i hold my
hair up so that it feels like i'm
dominating myself
you start combing your own hair while
you're trying to suck your own dick i
should probably share some information
about this i'm not gonna do the michael
jackson and [ __ ]
that's pretty good but when you do it
though do you before you do before you
suck your own penis do you slap your
face with your penis oh how degrading i
thought you meant just slap yourself
like normally would you do that anthony
and then [ __ ] jizz all over yourself
that's nick look at his face right now
the answer is yes to all of it dude or
like do you ask yourself hey am i going
to swallow a knob or do you want it on
your face oh
that's what you do if you're on a trip
away from home you're on a work trip bro
the last thing i want to do if i'm
trying to suck my own dick is look at
myself trying to suck my own dick dude
that's probably the worst thing you
don't want to see the strain on your
shame that's a shame i don't know dude
you know it might be valentine's day you
know you might need some company you
ever jack off and then catch yourself in
the mirror and you're like oh god what's
wrong with me don't look at me where
you're like
what's wrong with me
you just catch you catch your own look
in the in like a reflection somewhere
you're like oh people's over here like
this is the lowest point
that's not a pretty thing look at me
don't look at me oh no no so ugly like
you know those videos where people are
jacking off and then the webcams on they
didn't realize it
they look so they're always like
like it doesn't look good i gotta be
honest i don't know those videos
i'll send you some links bro
so a man has suffered a devastating back
injury after trying to suck his own
penis and this guy opened up on a reddit
post about the moment he heard a crack
during his latest attempt so apparently
he tried multiple times he's documenting
it on reddit apparently he explained
that this was certainly not the first
time he's tried to do the deed and to be
fair loads of men will have tried at
least once
loads of men that's not a correct
quantification no i love i love the word
loads yeah
he should have just taken [ __ ]
stretching class or yoga or something i
john i'm sure he probably tried and i
will i'll make sure he knows that you
feel this concern i feel so get the dark
knight bro if you're trying to suck your
own dick just get a machine that's going
to do it for you nothing can replicate
the lips that dark yeah but if you're
going to break your [ __ ] vertebrae if
i guys said that every attempt has been
a success oh oh good for you however the
most recent one clearly didn't go
according to plan one day as usual
getting ready to do my thing i did
stretches so i can be more elastic okay
so he did take yoga and then he said
today i [ __ ] up
wow so he had a process he had a system
he was successful and then just one time
he's got injury yeah he sucks his own
dick that much and he was just [ __ ]
slamming his [ __ ] face on his dick
real hard i don't know this was just a
photo associated with the article you
know that's the thing is it's such a
stock photo unless there's video i don't
believe it yeah that's true unless this
video i don't believe yeah i saw a porno
where a guy uh sucked his own dick but i
wasn't even looking for that on the
thumbnail
okay it was like two hot like russian
girls with this one dude right and i was
like oh [ __ ] a threesome video you know
very vanilla very very you know
predictable and then you click the video
you click the video in act three i'll
tell you
you know they're probably gonna do the
same format you know it's it's just
their good old threesome russian
categories right yeah no incest none of
that new school [ __ ] just threesomes not
in russia it's a protocol for threesome
classic none of that new testament form
the video starts
uh the video starts where
the
girls are spying on the dude and now
who's like in a hotel bed right and he
has his legs straight like this his legs
straight like this and he's just like
chilling and he goes down and he starts
sucking his own dick
and i'm all like
how well first of all he didn't have to
stretch that far he's pretty flexible
but he has a big dick and it passes his
belly button whoa
and he's like just sucking it right wow
and the girls are coming up like you
don't have to do that by yourself and
then i'm like that's [ __ ] hot and
then they [ __ ] and i'm like wow i mean
they could have caught him jacking off
but why did he suck his own dick yeah
that was just the weirdest yeah it threw
me off so much that i was like man i
can't jack off now it's all the ladies
that are watching this comment below if
you would
be interested in a threesome with a guy
if you call him suck his own dick
he's like
i'm running fast as [ __ ] i have to run
in this scene maybe he insisted huh yeah
he's like wait next thing i'm not gonna
jack off he never told the director he's
gonna do that the guy's like oh [ __ ]
this is cool and that's why i love
improv here guys
[Laughter]
ladies you're fired we don't we don't
need you today we're reaching to a solo
scene today it's just second city russia
that's what they're about
and
this wasn't even meant to be a porn but
okay we could sell this damn second city
russia would be crazy
and who's the porn director that wrote
this he goes okay so you're going to be
sucking your own dick and the girls are
going to spy on you and they're going to
be so horny that you're sucking your own
dick
they're going to do it for you
and i'm like
what
do you think that was this director's
like lifelong dream like he wrote a
script like the writer of the script
like you know a guy sucking his own dick
okay where are we gonna find this guy
though yeah and then like for 20 years
they couldn't find him they finally
found him like yes
they put the dust off the script yeah
dude finally we got it bring out old
betsy
it's analog it's like written
[Laughter]
maybe on the porn star resume too like
there's guys that are like i know you
know like in actors they'll be like i
know martial arts i could ride a
unicycle like they have all those
special things special skill sharks
so they [ __ ] scream the dudes that
can suck their own dicks dude like you
put that on your acting right that would
be like stand out you think you get
calls more probably i think so i think
you get more people going
for pornography
[Laughter]
wow
we just needed you to ride a bike but
okay
[Laughter]
hey let me ask you guys a question
though okay so let's say let's say like
your penis is so big that you just have
to bend your neck down to like suck it
wow i would try i don't think i would
finish myself
you finishing your eye like i get it no
but like if you had a penis that big
though you have to also imagine that
you're going to endure a lot of
rejection
because a lot of girls will see and go
oh no that is there's no way that's
coming inside of me like you're not so
you the guys with large penises they're
sure they brag about it and stuff but
they've probably been rejected
that's true like that's too that's too
big yeah and like they can never get it
all the way in yeah some girls you know
it's too painful they don't know what to
feel they don't know what that feels
like yeah they only have to deal with
like four hands on it you know yeah yeah
girls gotta [ __ ] [ __ ] it like this to
make it work oh man my huge dick problem
means that only three girls at a time
can feel like they're enjoying it
that's too [ __ ] big dude joe's skill
level yeah
those polynesian climbers
we're gonna get some coconuts bro
you